I mean growing up where I did the game  was around you and my family was a part  of the game at one point in time so I  learned much of it but I didn't think  nothing of it at one point in time I was  like this is quick and I don't play how  everybody else plays it so  how do you do it differently  I don't know about these girls but I'm  saying punctual and like  I'm the reason why I don't I ain't got  time for that when I see you five  minutes but somebody's going to me for  like 30 minutes  so if you're not going to pay a little  more for some more time I'm out you can  either take me back I'm awake  it's just to me  you think you could run over me when it  gets too long  and that's not what's gonna happen  I'm sweet I am but will you play about  my time and my money it's not okay  because I feel like you're playing with  me as a person  and to me it's just business I don't  have fun doing this I have fun getting  views